ce mois son coût représente l'espoir
d'être juriste l'antenne pour nous
ousmane son cou et l'a su éveiller
quelques chose que dormait toujours chez
les gens voient en duo thomas sankara
lumumba
à
l'époque le parti venait de naître il
avait besoin quand même des jeunes
je pense qu'il m'a pris deux fois au
franc fort avant de rejoindre au début
je le dis que moi je n'ai rien de
politique et que vraiment ça marche un
départ mais comme je dis il a l'art de
convaincre
d'expliquer la labourer les
issues et vraiment il a su me convaincre
l'assument au fait comment pour ce que
j'ignorais surtout cette fameuse phrase
qu'il a répétée à savoir si vous refusez
le faire de la politique les médiocres
voire le faire mobiliser de façon
médiocre laisse des regrets scène
ressemble médoc et vous ne pouvez
absolument rien
[Musique]
alos motion n'a plus comprendre que 90%
de nouveaux sites naturels actuellement
soit entre les pieds soit 28.2 parole en
ajoutant ça ne me sert pas d'autres
nations nous a non seulement aller
seulement éveiller les consciences mais
nous avons en réalité qu'au sénégal on a
tout ce dont on a besoin pour réussir on
entoure et florent tout pour développer
mais on est appauvrie par notre région
vous mission accomplie que cette
jeunesse cette place aussi jeune
quand le sénégal ne doit pas être
fardeau ces populations doit être un
tabou sauf un avantage au moins deux
pires et le sénégal vers le haut doubs
après soir à mardi soir à meaux du
droit
on est à la place de la nation une place
assez mutique symbolique pour tous les
cas révolutionnaire parce que cette
classe qui a abrité beaucoup de
normalisation et qu'on ne se sente
oculaire tant que le pouvoir la bourse
on nous l'a demandé est temps que tant
que les gens sont en train de diaboliser
je suis de cours à clé sur la bonne sur
la bonne voie
présentement savourer les abonnés dans
le ciel du soft le 16 mars 2021 pour
remercier le frappe d'avoir à portée
sociale
prenant
symbolise on peut chez nous thomas
sankara au mouloudia j'ai entendu aux
compacts bas parce qu'ils incarnent les
principes pour lesquels ces gens là se
battre et danse mention qu être leader
nationaliste africain qui aujourd'hui
prendre discours
panafricain qui aujourd'hui s'engage
aujourd'hui à lutter contre exemple la
souveraineté économique la vision
politique et le discours politique de
passage rejoigne quasiment les mêmes
causes les mêmes principes pour lesquels
le frappe se bat
l'asthme
alors voilà c'était à rufisque lors des
campagnes 2019 les présidentielles
avant on avait tendance à voir que les
femmes aient été là tout simplement pour
des décors chez beaucoup de partis
politiques dont beaucoup de partis
politiques autant pour moi aujourd'hui
c'est le contraire au niveau de passer
la femme elle s'affirme elle s'impose je
me suis dit pour sa part mme affirmé en
tant que j'ai et surtout en tant que
femme montrer la bonne voie parce que je
me dis qu'être dans le pastis et être
dans la bonne voie donc vous passez
c'est pourquoi j'ai invité toutes mes
copines d'autres personnes que je
connais à venir être dans le paquet mais
je tenais pas à militante au moins soit
une sympathisante aux biens ont suivi le
discours du leader jusqu'à ce qu'il te
convaincre comme ce que la lafa pour moi
c'est un nombre véridique
quand on est quelqu'un qui aime la
vérité
on doit aimer aux mains de son groupe